[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about what we want and we
got to hear a was Bobby I heard a key to
say that what is that it's Kenny it's
good it's Irish
no it's a it wasn't take it and roll
with it for me now I'm at this like
point in my life where I hear things and
I'm like that's what they're saying like
I'm not gonna take it and maybe I want
to slap someone yeah you're like shut up
you're stupid
really you got anger it's just do like
right now I think Isaac is in this phase
um where he's saying like bruh bruh this
is call you bro what do you know he's a
good kid like you won't do it but like
he's just sometimes because because we
have such a great relationship and like
we [ __ ] around a lot to like we're so
close in age we're like you know we'll
[ __ ] around so sometimes you'll forget
like oh I don't need to be respectful so
we check him and we hold on ya can't bro
your mom like my daughter too because
she's tall but yeah like we joked with
her like she's an adult sometimes cuz
he's she is mature for her age but she's
still a [ __ ] kid at times we had the
remodel oh yeah your [ __ ] kid sorry
damn cheese she's probably 511 oh [ __ ]
right in you oh yeah
she's taller than my mom 14:14 is that
learn to have your kid taller than you
no no cuz she can't hit I still punch
way harder there she can't work anything
on the inside I just step in and wow
[ __ ] up the ribs real quick like one of
these yeah those her Oh Kimmy's not
tearing man I have eleven at fourteen
that means she's still gonna grow yeah
it might be like six something it might
be but she doesn't wanna play basketball
this is she doesn't want to play what
does it mean you have to play basketball
not bounce you got me by the balls you
can play tennis you can make 45 of G's a
year between 45 is like 65 even like a
star player like what about one of the
star players now it's time I saw you
talk about something different about was
about sixty a part name a star player
that's the problem
Lamar Oh Johnson yeah that is now
could've been Judy Bryant
sure Oh Kobe's kids yeah oh I see you're
saying I'm like that you actually named
our WNBA all right there are star like
LA Sparks players I still know their
names because they're not that story
enough but they don't advertise the
games either that's the thing they don't
advertise the game because their
attendance isn't big enough for them to
feel like they have a market that's
gonna be the lucrative flip it's like LA
Galaxy [ __ ] I think yeah I don't think
anyone I really like about MMA is that
an MMA they can there's women and I'm a
that can headline a whole event yeah
which i think is super cool do they get
treated equally yeah like Ronda Rousey
was like the Conor McGregor of her time
oh yeah dudes yeah so it was so cool
it's cool to see like in like a macho
masculine sport that that was I think
the first sport were like women were
holding it down with them even in the
men they're equal paydays it was funny
as Ronda Rousey was on this Japanese
reality TV show and they had these
straight-up black belt judo dudes yeah
that came in and it was like five or ten
contestants and I tried to take her down
she made those dudes look like little
kids man it was Olympian well
you know the name Ronda Rousey than BJ
Penn who is my favorite MMA fighter of
all time that was true so that's that's
all and he's one of the [ __ ] legends
actually one of the godfathers so I
would say never made like it doesn't I
think it's more gender equal in that
professional sport because we're in
sports well right but if you're a woman
fighting a woman you really can [ __ ]
put on a show like I think that I think
that WNBA it's just the market for it is
like yo NBA is [ __ ] like like this
WNBA it's not that's true in comparison
the game action is different this is
different think that is also the fact
that they started so close at the round
the same time guys and women mmm hey
yeah it wasn't like it wasn't like yeah
it wasn't the gap that the NBA and the
WNBA had like that's that mean we're
talking what 20 20 30 year gap with the
ladies feel about to want a man you know
that movie yeah yeah I feel like that
just made WNBA a joke look at how that
behavior back then
no don't wanna man that you remember the
guy like he for those of you I don't
know like this basketball player he ends
up getting kicked out of the NBA and so
he still wants to play ball so he ends
up joining like he dresses like a woman
and joins the WNBA but like to me that
was the first honestly the first
introduction to WNBA hadn't even know it
existed so to me Oh like I registered I
was like WNBA is a joke
because he's like he kept making jokes
of it to like it wasn't something to
take seriously I mean it is it is a joke
in a lot of ways it is they brought it
back at the end oh no but but okay so
what's so interesting what the part of
the [ __ ] of our culture is that if
you were to feel like yo everybody we're
all gonna throw a ball as far as we can
today right mm-hmm
more people are gonna watch just to see
the ball go farther than ever then like
hey now the chicks are gonna do it and
they're not gonna throw it quiet as far
it's just that's that's just how we all
are right I want to see the record get
set I want to see the farthest thing
it's more visually stimulating I'm not
saying it's right or whatever it's just
that that's part of the [ __ ]
right because in tennis it
some more gender like much you're not
really looking at it because there's
women players that are [ __ ] killing
it right but then when it comes to our
work yeah cuz if I mean there's you know
like the the lingerie football league or
whatever and like it's just unless
they're sexualized it's not the same
there's no gimmick as far as the skill
set goes what it really is in tennis
so it's the same with I think that's why
the NBA in the WNBA it's not that it's
not very gender neutral whatever you
call it because the skill set it's
completely different and maybe like you
said it's more of a masculine sport to
where you know with the charging and the
fouls in the dunking like if you become
accustomed to seeing that in a game and
now there's this other version of this
game that doesn't really show that as
much about it's a different game and
they do you know interesting to watch it
so but with tennis is all about control
so like you could like I don't mean when
I took private tennis lessons my tennis
coach was big he's a big guy he was fat
okay but he would literally stand at the
tee and had me running all over cuz he
had such amazing control with the racket
and follow-through like he didn't have
to do anything when I finally got good
like then he would just hit drop shots
and have me run into the [ __ ] net the
entire time and then I'd be in no-man's
land here toss a lob right over my head
again so he was he had amazing control
with it and like that's why I tennis is
so dope like I love tennis and I was
I'll tell my daughter like no good at
that [ __ ] you can go pro up for 1415 and
get out my house your sister's they make
a ton of [ __ ] money well into their
wait are they in their 40s now the
biggest [ __ ] and some of the biggest
athletes in the world are the sisters
the Serena do they separate men and
women in tennis yes it doesn't make the
woman's side less entertaining though
it's still thick you still see some
sexism in because like when guys show
emotion and smack their racket on the
alright yeah he's committed he's sold
Serena just went through that yeah but
what she did it all she's emotional she
can't control her emotions on court and
see like the guys is or they're so
passionate about the game and in the end
the mass was like bro [ __ ] like
deep I'm always in all women I won't
always be rooting for women they go
through so much more than us they handle
[ __ ] so much better than us and I will
always be a plus I call [ __ ] when
guys who like all she's too emotional
right man I've cried before I'm not
gonna back like I don't get emotional
I'm not as emotional as other people but
women hold it down bro I couldn't go to
the cramps every I would like take this
uterus out I don't want it
yeah what's the times before I was like
oh I would spayed myself if I had to go
through the everyone I take my dick I
don't want I want to be a kid dog house
down at the end of a [ __ ] Super Bowl
when the other team loses there's
confetti going down of the other teams
like colors and the guys are sitting
there like nobody's like you know there
fuk could be a [ __ ] out here of the
way that we all are even just
evolutionarily right like like we all
were we came from very primitive
backgrounds like so when somebody does
something we've never seen before with
something that it's like well that's so
hard to do so much more interesting but
female figure skating nobody gives a
[ __ ] about male figure skating sickest
like version of figure skating because
seeing dudes do it they're male
synchronized swimmers exactly I don't
even [ __ ] know if they're and I don't
want to not watching them yeah I don't
want to know how about that I don't
understand how like like what is that
water polo is that an Olympic sport yeah
I think I would have [ __ ] like what
whose dream is to be I wanna be an
Olympic water polo player like nobody's
nobody's giving cereal deals in [ __ ]
water like what are you who you speedo
oh you're getting deals from brand deals
really maybe maybe you you'd probably
crossover to swimming so you'd be like
Michael Phelps oh [ __ ] yeah yeah Michael
Phelps guys soon buddy I mean he also
was the absolute best like six gold
medals ooh who could you name before
Michael Phelps nobody but after like
rhyme line Mike Ryan Locker there you go
yeah that's the [ __ ] that lad
in Mexico and that was hard that was
hard for me to try to pull in the end
you did the only reason why I knew
because of his drama yeah yeah like
before Michael felt I guess you have to
be like the leader or like the Michaels
the go oh my God all of em pians I think
he's the number one or number two most
gold medals of all time come on hug from
him does not feel like you get wrap his
arms around twice the shoulders a [ __ ]
is crazy no watching me that's why I'm
watching me [ __ ] calories is to
consume in one smokes we get beautiful
abs gals in calories and because he
practices like [ __ ] for hours he's
like he's like guys can we order another
pizza like Mike what's been six pizzas
and he's like [ __ ] starving it's been
six minutes is what I'm saying
order a [ __ ] pizza CDs pulls out this
[ __ ] drunk is [ __ ] calories he's
drinking beers for calories okay then
what daughter took karate for seven
years I still can't take a punch
I play maybe you should change your
schools I just took her out of it like
like my chocolate yet she says you'd
liked it I went to like all of the
graduation ceremonies done all that and
she was doing the Coty's and the blocks
and all of that so one more time just
got up and tried to scare her I do that
and I'm thinking she going man took you
right to the chest I was like you
[ __ ] you can turn the chest yeah and
this you have to stay at home because
that I can't send it with a bruise on
her chest
Oh ruin my day see that that's what's
not fair about it right if you were to
tell me hey we're all gonna do a demo
right now where a guy's gonna [ __ ]
take 12 concrete slabs he's gonna
[ __ ] put his fist through all of them
I'm again I'm watching it right and then
if you tell me after that that a girl's
gonna do four I'm getting a hot dog
[Music]
it's just not fair sometimes I mess up I
was just visualizing my [ __ ] I was like
oh my god like [ __ ] I don't know what's
gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ] right now in case
of the disabled [ __ ] something watch my
security cams though anytime my home is
being built everyone's like Kindle
[ __ ] cried karate the only ones fort
that does that was like judo do they do
that [ __ ] oh like what why why is the
way to us about throws cries not strikes
the real reason why they break [ __ ] yeah
it's mental it's like mind over matter
yeah
gave you all obstacles interesting it's
also just sick-looking yeah I was a
karate really badly when I was little I
think I wonder what kind of person I
would have turned out to be if I did way
better
we probably would have to add this to
the list of you know regrets okay
please oh it's a new entry Oh No yes
karate piano guitars swimming literally
I can gymnastics ballet
I started closing Claudio three years
ago no two years ago you could still do
it I couldn't wait now I'm at this point
where I'm like I'd rather be miserable
of the fact that I couldn't do it in my
childhood that listen I've settled into
this chair I'm in my late 20s my life is
over here we start anything no I can't
that's it so you push it on Isaac though
do I push on Isaac oh that's our doctor
doctor if you get yeah he's telling us
not family enjoy push on Isaac no I mean
no but I guess like for us we were
trying to give him some extracurricular
activity so he did do swimming for some
time and he was killing it and then um
but then I don't know why we stopped
taking him but we did we stop and then
we ended up taking it was he bored of it
or like no he actually liked it
I forgot what happened I think we took a
trip like a really long trip and then we
ended up missing the lessons and yeah I
broke up them the momentum so then
remember the confidence I remember pre I
uh pre swimming Isaac you know he would
you'd see him I really want to get in
the pool but he's kind of scared and
he's like walking around I'm Brody had
those inflatable things yeah and then I
remember like after swimming Isaac he
just dives in all the time is swimming
away you know this stroke you see us
conference go through the roof she's
gone been like after afterwards I asked
ended up asking him like okay well
because then we got back from the
vacation whatever and I'm like oh you
know you're swimming it's Benson it's
been a while I we we forgot about your
swimming so then he was like I actually
want to try something else and then he
got really into piano and that's when we
we bought a piano you
oh you bought a piano yeah
right now the keyboard but the actual
piano piano a smart piano that teaches
you to know electronic piano yeah not
rich not that bad it's not like it's
like a hundred - right it was just a
thousand you're thinking of a baby grand
yes I was thinking I was like you say oh
you say I bought a piano and not like I
bought a keyboard I'm thinking I three
movers and got a moving fine child
sitting in the Libero with no it's not
bad
I'm right there with you yeah what is
the matter oh because you know because
you love your son no because oh cool
you got into piano a little bit I bought
you a baby grand piano that would be
nuts yeah
Marquand would do we did that wall my
mom got uh she got a used panel for us
okay till tyka [ __ ] says anything
like about what he wants to do you're
gonna fall Freight [ __ ] do all of it
I have no doubt in my mind you've got a
drugs up I'd buy him a drum says there's
there's cheaper yeah you get a piano for
like a couple hundred bucks yeah for
like 160 $160 for a baby drum since it's
kind of like fake like you can't really
play any beats on it first seven
Christmases it's not it's a baby's drum
set for seven campuses in a row demands
cheap because my Trump said if I were to
buy it now it'd be like $7,000 geez the
idea how does that your baby now kids
who did John have birthday parties from
one answer just one uh-huh that's crazy
all right
if I have another kid and I haven't
birthday parties until I pop he's not
gonna remember this [ __ ] I wouldn't talk
about this [ __ ] Lucy they'll start
remembering five no [ __ ] birthday
that's enough
the one year is none that s it yeah the
winner was for us to show all of
everyone like we [ __ ] were able to
keep this child life for a year so is a
celebration look we kept this hill with
a lot yeah yeah that's it a second year
everyone does keep it alive til one
this is Trudeau say the Great Depression
fashion spree this year is gonna be in
12 2008 yeah oh wait 2008 that same year
Isaac was born whoa January born it's
you doesn't mean yes thousand eight they
complain about Christmas presents you
know you guys both know okay we don't
know we don't punch him up
I remember 2008 like that was so yeah so
after the whole piano thing and then we
were giving him lessons like taking him
to a whole bunch of lessons and then he
just kept complaining about going to the
lessons he would never practice I'm like
why are we spending the money on these
lessons do that he's got a beat on this
yeah no but like I didn't want to get it
so I gave him this like listen we're at
these crossroads if we continue will you
do you think like you know you can
eventually like appreciate it and be
like oh you know that hard work paid off
I have this skill I can use it whatever
I know it's a difficult ass to ask a
child just too young for the foresight I
understand but um but then I ended up
asking him that and I said or are you is
it gonna go in this other route of we're
gonna keep forcing you to go you're
gonna complain every single time you're
never gonna practice you're gonna hate
it you're gonna end up resenting piano
and it's gonna be the worst thing of
your life and he ended up being like I
just I don't know and I'm like okay well
you know what this can save me some
money so we're just not we're gonna put
it away for now we have the piano at
home if you want to pick it up you know
how to pick it up like and like I said
it's a smart piano like plug in the the
iPad and he could do his lessons if he
wanted to something like you can push
yourself to do it if it's that
important to you right I'm like it takes
you know it takes time to drive out
there it's a lot of money and it's just
a lot of dedication if it was really a
smart piano it would be like hey kid I
don't think you're gonna really do this
I'm just saying you ever touch me all
week
well not really feeling like thirty-one
days ago okay
[Music]
[Music]